Hi, welcome to the Anna and Ashley show.
I'm Ashley and I'm Ann.
And today we will be talking to you
about holiday stress and ways you can help yourself
produce it.
But before we get started,
please hit the like and subscribe button
and if you're watching on YouTube,
hit the alert button so then you never miss an episode.
So we will be introducing a couple of products here
that we have that we've created a bundle on.
Yes, holiday stress, so the season is upon us.
And really, stress can be defined as anything
that causes the disturbance in our physiology.
So it could be extreme temperature, so hot or cold.
It can be psychological stress.
It can be physical stress.
It can be work overload.
What you perceive you have to do.
Physical trauma as well.
So all of these things can be considered stress.
And when we're approaching the holiday season,
we have multiple things coming at us.
We're short in time.
We have our regular jobs.
We have all of the other things to do
that the holidays involve.
We have family engagement, so all of these things
create this stress.
So what we've created here for you
is a black Friday bundle.
Basically, it's our favorite stress-reducing products here.
The first one that we're going to talk about
is the CBD oil.
So this is pure CBD oil.
It's capsules.
And it's from a company called Canway.
And they are a well-known professional brand.
Really thorough in their testing.
The thing with CBD oil is you want to make sure
that you're getting it from a reputable source
where the plants are not being sprayed
with herbicides and pesticides.
Where they're not using GMOs.
So really tested.
And this is a great product.
It's triple tested for herbicides and pesticides.
There's no THC in this.
So if you happen to be drug tested for work,
this is not going to show up.
There's no THC in there.
And then it's also got the US hemp authority seal of approval.
So this is a great product.
Not only does it help alleviate stress,
it can help with pain.
So it reduces inflammation,
which can reduce that pain response.
So it helps with the pain,
inflammation, stress, and anxiety.
And it really works to just calm the central nervous system.
So we are overall just more calming
and relaxed state.
So that is one of our favorite products here.
Yes.
And then we also have some famine here made by US enzymes.
And so this one is going to be the stress reducer
is coming from the L-theanine,
which was actually found specifically in teas.
And then they created this formula to incorporate
that amino acid.
So it reduces stress while improving your mental focus
without having the drowsiness, such as very unique.
And then it also helps prevent caffeine jitters, too,
as some of the research.
Yeah, it improves quality of sleep,
your learning performance,
and it also supports the immune system.
Clinical research also suggests that 50 to 200 milligrams
is going to naturally simulate the brain's activity
and to the alpha wave,
which is going to be associated with the relaxed
but alert mental state.
So that is our product, sun, the anine here.
And then the last product here is called adaptoclear.
And again, we use this a lot in our clinic.
So this has a combination of adaptogenic herbs,
which are herbs that have been scientifically proven
to really help with stress resistance.
So if you're running high and stressed,
it helps bring you back to balance.
And if you're running low, you know,
feeling like you're lacking motivation or low in your mood,
it can help bring it up.
So it's adaptogenic.
It's also got co-factors,
which help with all of the metabolic pathways
that help us relieve the stress
and improve the stress resiliency.
So it's got the co-factors, minerals as well
that are the co-factors.
But then the adaptogenic herbs are really the piece
that's helping with the stress response.
Roviola is one of them.
Most people have probably heard of Roviola.
Again, it's supporting the nervous system.
It's helping with mood regulation, mental clarity,
work performance, and that helps with the sleep cycle.
It will throw root extract,
can support memory and physical endurance,
also supports being in the system.
It's got Shassandra Berry extract,
which supports learning and memory as well.
And again, all of these are helping with that stress response
and licorice root extract.
And then also Ashwaganda.
So Ashwaganda is another one that is really beneficial
for people who are under extreme stress.
And the beauty of this product
is that all of these adaptogenic herbs,
well, great as an individual herb to help with stress.
When you put them all together,
it really works on a synergistic level
to just get the most performance out
of these stress-improving or stress-resiliency
improving products.
So that one is a great one.
So again, these three are in her bundle.
We also have a few essential oils we sent out
because most of you probably have essential oils at your home,
so don't forget to use them
just as you're prepping your house maybe
or getting things ready for whatever it is you have going on.
Just simply diffuse them.
Some ones that we would recommend would be a stress away
if you have that lavender.
And then peppermint and peace and calming.
So some great options just to have around your house,
plus it'll make your house smell good too.
Calm everybody down, baby.
And then some extra tips here.
Be realistic with the time that you have
to achieve what it is you want to achieve.
Don't be super stressed about it.
Obviously, this is our topic.
Take some support if you need to,
but otherwise your timeline that you provided for yourself
just don't be so hard on yourself
if you don't reach something you wanted to.
Again, it's the holidays.
We're all kind of on that level, but perfection,
it's okay if you're not.
That would be perfect.
Something's bound to go around.
So laugh at yourself if there's a mistake
and have some sense of humor with it.
Kind of roll with the flow of something
doesn't go your way and that's truly what matters.
Also ask for help.
Everybody that I know that you've gone to someone
that's hosting their house.
They always ask if there's something they can do.
They truly mean it.
Let them help you.
If they don't make it feel like it's just all on you
it never is.
There's always people who want to support you.
And then always know when to say no.
So if someone's asking your opinion,
tell them no if it will stress you out.
If you truly don't think it will, then of course they yes.
But otherwise, no one just say no
and have boundaries this holiday.
That's a good one.
Also find your calm during the storm.
So of course on the day celebration, the morning of
or even leading up to it.
Make sure you take time to admire those around you.
The prep work that you've already put in
if you got your tree decorated.
Just take time to admire the beautiful decorations you have done
or if you slay a dull day or cleaning your house,
make sure you take time to appreciate
the work that you'd have put in.
So the little things and then of course on the day
I remember it's most important is spending time
with those that you love and everybody that's there
to support you and enjoy the holiday with you.
Take that time in and sip the wine a little longer
and take the pictures with your friends and families
and just really enjoy each other's company.
Yes, because really that's what it's all about.
And hopefully these tips are going to help you.
Remember on our store to search for the Black Friday bundle,
it will bring you to this bundle
and then use the code Black Friday
so you can get free shipping on this.
We hope you enjoyed this episode with some of these tips
for getting through the holidays, stress free
and please again, if you found this valuable,
share this video with your friends
because they might need some help as well
and stay tuned for next episode.
Take care.